hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and this week
you are in luck because i'm going to be
answering a load of your property
investment questions right now
however if your question doesn't get
answered
maybe you've been asking questions in
the previous video and i'll answer it
right now
but the reason you're in luck is because
i'm going to be
answering all of the comments in this
video on
next q a sunday's video so if you're
watching this now
and you've got a question about property
investment now is your opportunity
comment below in this video also if i'm
answering some other questions
and something like shoots into your head
or an offshoot of a question
comment below and i'm going to do my
very best to answer your question
next week however let's have a look at
some of the questions that came from the
last video like this there's been some
very interesting questions
um with a guy called aziz savage who
said
would you advise us to send out landlord
letters for lease option agreements as
an hmo with the current covid19
situation
i know landlords are more motivated to
sell now however
what if you struggle to fill the hmo due
to the lockdown or what if the tenants
start to leave
due to them not being able to afford the
rent from the job losses
would it be best to just get everything
ready and then wait until lockdown has
been removed
as is i would say that now is an
absolutely fantastic time to be sending
out landlord letters
about lease option agreements and the
reason is exactly as you've said you've
said
the tenants could move out the lockdown
the fear
all the problems but that's the reason
why you're able to go in right now and
get a really good deal bear in mind you
are the investor you're the person
that's trying to
get a deal so as a property investor
property investors go around looking for
bargains
like now is the time to go and get a
bargain
now is the time to go and get a good
deal it's crazy because
normally if there's a sale on something
everyone queues up to buy you know if
there's a sale on
clothes a clothes sale everyone flocks
to buy and get the good deals
but when there's a sale on house it
houses and there's a sale going on right
now in the property market and
everyone's like ah and they're selling
stuff off at 20
30 discounts the crazy thing is when
that happens
investors don't queue up investors go
ooh
but it could get cheaper it could get
worse like it's it's it's
i don't get it like so one billion
percent as is you should be sending out
letters
you should be trying to get deals and in
terms of what about
the tenants and the lockdown and the
situation well depending on what you
arrange
if you're arranging a lease option
agreement you could you could arrange it
to start from when lockdown finishes or
you could say listen
let's but listen by the time everything
goes through and all the paperwork go
through we'll probably be down
out of lockdown anyway now's the time to
negotiate good deals but only good deals
you know you if you're going to be
buying a property right now or taking
our deal right now
you want to be 100 be getting a
very very good deal most millionaires
are made
through recessions and crisis so if
you're not a millionaire yet
now is your freaking chance get to work
that's my advice
sam e says hey samuel big fan of the
channel i'm 18 years old and start
university in the summer
let's hope that you do i'll be
definitely coming to one of your two day
courses after this coronavirus is all
done
awesome hope to see you there sam
basically my situation is that i've ten
thousand pound in savings and parents
that are supportive but don't have money
i can have or borrow
i am looking at buying a house
approximately a hundred thousand pound
in newcastle
have two or three friends happy to pay
50 pounds a week to rent a room
i would be living there too i then plan
to get into rent to rent and i want to
try out deal packaging in the meantime
to raise funds i just wanted to know
what your thoughts are on this and if
you have any advice
i understand you're a very busy man blah
blah blah blah blah
i said blah blah blah because i'm too
busy to continue reading and i'm just
kidding great listen
dude i think you're going to be really
successful i think your
your your key is you just got to focus
so you're talking about
you know i want to try this and i want
to try this and i then want to try this
you don't want to try and do anything
you know this is not a
this is not a trying exercise this is
just a what's the process and then i'm
going to do it
and in your mind you're talking about
buying a house renting rooms out to your
friends by the way that's an awesome
plan
that's something that's very very smart
if you can buy a property and then rent
rooms out to your friends
it's just it's just a winning formula if
you don't mind living with friends it's
tax efficient
it's it's a fantastic idea for young
people to do
then you're talking about rent to rent
and deal packaging i would say just
focus on one thing
go and find that house in newcastle that
you want to buy
get a really freaking good deal and see
if you can get finance on it
um mortgages are you can get a mortgage
right now banks are lending
but it's difficult because the
valuers can't go and visit the property
but if you start getting some properties
lined up right now
ready for lockdown to be finished and
then i think you should just need to
start
one thing at a time but sounds like a
great plan good job
i hope you guys agree if you like the
sound of sam e's plan comment below tell
him he's a rock star tell him he's going
to win
lelone hi samuel i'd like you to answer
my questions please
here i am when doing a lease option with
a vendor
are you doing legal work with the
solicitor do you pay stamp duty on the
start of the lease option
or when you actually buy the property
with a loan or a mortgage
okay so when you're doing a lease option
agreement no you don't pay any stamp
duty
until you actually exchange title deeds
which will usually be years and years
down the line so
you don't pay stamp duty you don't pay
any taxes the only fee you have to pay
is a one pound option
fee to the seller to make the contract
binding legally
and then you need to pay a sinister
that's it hope that helps
tom pigart the eviction season two
when's it coming
so i was thinking about the eviction
actually the other day the eviction was
a
series that i did and it was it was
pretty good actually we basically
lived i lived in a castle and had 12 or
13
uh delegates and every we did a task
every few days and then the weakest link
was evicted and then the winner got 20
000 pounds and the winner was actually
anthony wilmart who's now a really good
friend of mine
and i don't know if i ever will do an
eviction
series 2. i mean to be honest i'd
forgotten all about it until you just
mentioned it so
maybe i will if enough people want to
see it i'll probably do it once we're at
a lockdown eviction two
i'm open to the suggestion so thanks for
the comment lewis poll
what's the legality if i do a lease
option agreement and move
into the property lots of lease option
agreement questions i'm loving it
with two housemates and use rent to pay
the mortgage for the owner with the
option to buy
or is there a better way to do something
like this i think that sounds good
listen as long as the
if you've got a mortgage on the property
as long as you are not changing the use
of the property
against the um against the lender's
requirements so if you're doing a lease
optional
agreement on a house that's got a
residential mortgage and then you want
to rent it out
you're going to need to get consent from
the lender but as long as you're not
breaking any of the lender's rules on
the house
then yeah that that that makes sense so
good plan lewis i hope it works out keep
me posted
t chanakiri says hi samuel i hope you're
well as an experienced property investor
like yourself with such a huge property
portfolio mainly hmos
is it stressful to manage so many
tenants
and what tips would you give to someone
like me who wants a big portfolio
but not a lot of daily headaches from
tenants great question so a couple of
things firstly is
um tenants yeah tenants are work tenants
are customers
and people that say oh tenants that's so
much work isn't it a pain
i've heard landlords say this kind of
thing and joke about how they're
allergic to tenants i think that's
stupid because
the tenants are the people that actually
pay your bills so you need to treat them
like customers and value them
however they do come with hassles
so what i personally do is a few things
i have management companies
which is really helpful i also have an
overseer so i have someone who manages
the property managers
so in other words if there's a problem
if if a tenant's got a problem they call
the property manager
and if the property manager can't handle
it they contact the overseer and the
overseer is the only person who's
allowed to speak to me so for me it's
not a lot of work
however you're talking about having a
really big portfolio and stuff um
i don't necessarily think when i started
out in property i was like i want to
have hundreds of houses
and then when i started to get lots of
houses you know i thought actually do i
want hundreds of houses
or do i actually want to just make more
money and do i want to be a great
experienced wealthy property investor so
i actually
um started selling off some of my
smaller houses to put into bigger deals
so it's not a case of who has the most
houses wins
it's a case of actually who's helping
the most people who's making good money
who's making the economy better because
as a result of that kind of thing
as a result of providing good
accommodation for people as a result of
being a good landlord as a result of
adding value you're always the money's
always going to follow
so you know i would just say don't even
worry about it too much just make sure
you've got good systems in place you've
got
property management companies and and
you'll be fine and make sure you're a
really good landlord and look after your
tenants so anyway i know there's a
long-winded answer to a short question
hope that helps and i look forward to
seeing you in the next video okay
reza martin samuel my man
sale agreed one month ago on a good
great better than good not great okay
bye to that should i still go ahead with
the crisis upon us now
do i have room to renegotiate a lower
house sale price due to the market
crashing
where's that yes you do have room to
renegotiate if you put an offer on a
property and it was accepted
a month or so back before all this
absolute madness happens
and now the sale is progressing i would
100
try and renegotiate now if the deal was
you said it was good but not great if it
was great and you were like oh my gosh
i'm gonna make
so much money on this deal and and
the coronavirus the property dipping at
the moment wasn't really going to affect
that too much then i might say okay well
maybe go ahead but i 100 think you worry
it have it's not an unreasonable thing
should we say for you to try and
renegotiate right now
given the circumstances so yeah i would
and i think property prices are they're
predicted to go down around about 15
percent this year
so to try and get an extra 10 off would
be very reasonable
in my opinion hope that helps all right
last
question but don't forget to comment
your questions we're gonna do one more
question
also if you're enjoying the video smash
the like button comment below
this is from harry penfold he says hi
samuel i'm looking to
buy my first hmo with the help of my
parents
good for you harry it would be a 50 50.
however we're struggling to find a
mortgage we can't get a mortgage as i'm
too young
and also me nor my parents have any
landlord experience
however we have enough for a deposit
we've looked at ways around it
one way would be to borrow against our
house but my parents are understandably
reluctant to do this do you have any
suggestions
great question harry a few things i'll
say number one is you want to make sure
you've got a really good mortgage broker
because
it might be that you're being told you
can't get a mortgage by
a bank but actually if you went to an
independent mortgage broker
who looked at all the banks they'd say
that you can't get a mortgage that's the
very first thing i do
second thing is it might be worth for
your first project
not being a hmo so start with a small
buy to let property
and then get a bit of experience and
then get a hmo and what you'll find is a
lot of that will open you up to a lot of
a lot of lenders because they'll see
that you have landlord experience
the third option i guess is to borrow
against the house they've said that's an
option but i understand your parents
aren't too keen on doing that but i
think that those are those are the three
things i said on top of my head
try a different broker or find an
independent mortgage broker
start with a different type of property
or borrow against the house they need
three options
but hey you've got great parents and i
hope that you are wildly successful
so listen guys that's it from me today i
hope you found this video useful i hope
you found it beneficial
next sunday at 7 p.m i'm gonna be
answering all the questions from
this video so comment your questions
below
if you're not subscribed to the channel
please do subscribe and turn on the
notification bell
and i look forward to seeing you next
week thanks so much peace out